Alice: 听歌
Alice: Listening to music.
Alice: 终于可以拆了我再也忍不了这个
Alice: Finally, I can open this. I can't stand it anymore.
Alice: 你懂吧
Alice: You get it, right?
Alice:这个窗帘你要不要
Alice: Do you want this curtain?
Alice: 不对这叫啥
Alice: No wait, what's it called?
Alice: 壁布
Alice: Wallpaper.
刘婷:行 可要之
Liu Ting: Sure, I'll take it.
Alice: 你说话中
Alice: You're speaking...
Alice: 又土又洋气
Alice: Both tacky and stylish.
Alice: 你说呢
Alice: What do you think?
Alice: 我这个灯亮着呢吧
Alice: Is my light on?
刘婷:灯亮着呢
Liu Ting: The light is on.
Alice: 好着呢
Alice: It's good.
Alice: 你这贴的真是
Alice: You really stuck this well.
刘婷:你贴得挺结实的现在还没掉是吧
Liu Ting: You stuck it quite firmly, it's still holding on, right?
刘婷:哎哟哟哟
Liu Ting: Oh my goodness.
Alice:你要这灯串不要
Alice: Do you want this string of lights?
Alice: 这个你要不要刘婷
Alice: Do you want this, Liu Ting?
Alice: 特别方便
Alice: It's very convenient.
Alice: 你看我这个
Alice: Look at mine.
刘婷:太成熟了哈哈哈
Liu Ting: It's too mature, haha.
Alice: 就是
Alice: Exactly.
Alice: 你看这个是可就是可以粘墙上什么的
Alice: Look, this can be stuck on the wall and such.
Alice: 然后这个我都没掉就只有这一点点
Alice: And this hasn't fallen off, just a tiny bit.
Alice: 然后你看
Alice: And look,
Alice: 魔术贴
Alice: Velcro.
Alice: 然后这个你想贴哪
Alice: And wherever you want to stick this,
Alice: 你把这个胶弄到哪就行
Alice: Just put the glue there.
Alice: 并且我选的这个我觉得质量还挺好的
Alice: And I think the quality of this one I chose is pretty good.
Alice: 你看这挺好看的这个你摸摸这个质量
Alice: Look, it looks nice. Feel the quality of this.
Alice: 选的不错的
Alice: It's a good choice.
Alice: 那你拿走吧
Alice: You can take it.
刘婷:好的 好像你之前是这个
Liu Ting: Okay. It seems like before you,
刘婷:每个屋子的东西都报了
Liu Ting: Reported the stuff in every room.
Alice: 是的 每人500
Alice: Yes, each person gets 500.
刘婷:喔可以啊
Liu Ting: Oh, that's good.
Alice: 不超过500
Alice: No more than 500.
Alice: 这窗帘真的很像婚纱的质地
Alice: This curtain really feels like wedding dress material.
Alice: 所以做婚纱为什么不能用窗帘的布呢
Alice: So why can't we use curtain fabric for wedding dresses?
Lucia: 可能说亲肤吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe because it's skin-friendly, haha.
Tasha: 可能用的是一块布
Tasha: Maybe it's just a piece of cloth
Tasha: 但是为了显肤
Tasha: but to show skin
Alice:确实
Alice: 妈呀吓我一跳
Alice: Oh my, that scared me
Alice: 我以为他走了
Alice: I thought he left
Alice: 有点臭
Alice: It smells a bit
Lucia: 洗一下
Lucia: Wash it
Alice:有一股工厂的味
Alice: It smells like a factory
Lucia: 对 新的这些布料
Lucia: Yeah, these new fabrics
Lucia: 应该都是这样的
Lucia: are usually like that
Alice:没事 不用洗了
Alice: It's fine, no need to wash it
Alice: 让刘婷拿着玩吧
Alice: Let Liu Ting play with it
Alice:不用
Alice: No need